once you start opening your heart
it begins to move into coherence it
begins to produce a measurable magnetic
field up to
three meters wide now that's frequency
that's energy
and all that energy that frequency
carries information carries an intent
so then when you're feeling gratitude
and your heart is open you're
broadcasting energy into the field a
frequency you lay the intent of the
thought of your health to your wealth
that frequency can carry the thought of
your wealth if you're suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know the moment you disconnect
from the energy of your future because
of some circumstance in your life and
you lose that feeling if you're
practicing it on a daily basis with your
eyes closed then the next level is to be
able to open your eyes and do it right
in the moment and be able to
self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future that requires great awareness and
great effort but if you have a community
of people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where
their mind is
they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements to know
that we can teach people how to do that
and we have evidence that people can
sustain it
for 45 minutes to an hour it's a skill
now they know that they know how to do
it so now they have brain coherence and
heart coherence well once the heart
begins to become orderly and coherent it
acts as an amplifier and it drives
energy to the brain so now the brain is
getting more energy once the heart is
open and then you're thinking different
set of thoughts and those thoughts
produce different chemicals for you to
feel more of that and here comes
uh nitric oxide from oxytocin and all of
a sudden your heart literally starts to
swell it literally begins to open up
there's more energy going there and now
you're coming from a different level of
mind
when you have coherence in the brain and
heart you have a laser of energy and it
could read information much better
you're living in stress and your brain
is shifting its attention from one
person to another problem to another
thing to another
place to go
each one of those things there's an
assignment of neurological networks in
the brain so the arousal of the stress
hormones drives the brain into this high
frequency and you're trying to control
and predict everything in your life and
those your brain circuits are firing
like a like a lightning storm in the
clouds when your brain's incoherent
you're incoherent and and you can't you
don't have a signal you're you don't
have a wi-fi sitting not connected to
the field how could you how could you
connect to energy and information if
your signal hasn't become order
so that when people synchronize their
energy into coherence they can
synchronize to a possibility in the
future and the synchronicities
that are feedback from the environment
are just a reflection of your energy and
that's the universe saying
follow the breadcrumbs do it again
follow it again do it again and now all
of a sudden the person's not waking in
the morning like oh
i gotta meditate now to create my future
they're kind of going like i'm getting
out of bed because i don't want the
magic to end right they want to they
want to sustain that state so that
the old
reality that they've lived in begins to
transform into something new and because
there's no longer a vibrational match
with everyone and everything in their
past present reality there's a
vibrational match to their future and
now their future is starting to give
them signals thoughts
to me produce an electrical charge in
the quantum field
and feelings produce a magnetic charge
in the quantum field and how you think
and how you feel
broadcast an electromagnetic signature
that influences every single atom in
your life the thought sends the signal
out i think about this and the feeling
draws the event back so you could have
the intent that you want wealth you want
health you want success that's your
intent that's your thought but if you're
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel it then you're not
drawing the experience to you because
you're not feeling the emotion right so
then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it
however you want to jump on that cycle
and then sustain it because the longer
you're conscious of that energy
the more you're drawing your future to
you and i hear this from so many people
gabby i'm doing it all i'm meditating
i'm praying i'm setting intentions
creating vision boards but i'm not
manifesting one reason you're not
manifesting is because you don't believe
in what you're trying to manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just
trying pushing controlling trying to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy
and so you have to do your part to get
into the belief system of knowing that
this is indeed something you are worthy
of so how do you get into that grounded
belief system create a vision statement
a statement that claims that your desire
is on the way that you are worthy of
what it is that you desire ground
yourself in that statement
focus on it and instead of focusing on
the outcome focus on the feeling of what
it is to believe and know that you are
worthy of your desire
if you're wanting to attract
a romantic partner into your life a
vision statement could sound like i
believe i'm worthy of the love that i
desire
where i believe that i am ready to
receive that romantic relationship in
the perfect time and order say that
vision statement daily for at least 40
days get yourself grounded in the belief
you have to believe it to receive it the
next reason you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
i'm sorry to say it but it's true the
more you push the more you control the
more you try the more you affirm the
more you vision board the more the more
the more
the less you receive
if you're pushing and you're controlling
and you're trying to make something
happen you're completely out of
alignment with the universe you're not
aligned with that freedom that presence
of love the art of allowing
rather than
doing forcing making happen
yeah we have to show up for our life but
we can't force our dreams to become our
reality so the key here is to let go so
here's your message the secret to
manifesting is to forget what you think
you need
let it go how do you let it go
with this intention
thank you universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all
when you make it about the highest good
and not about what you think you need
then the universe can truly show up for
you you can relax and allow
even more than you could imagine to
enter into your life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what gaby what do you mean
well what i mean is that you're leaning
into the negative you're judging a lot
you're focusing on scary things that
make you so anxious and you just keep
focusing on them and dwelling on them
you're obsessed with worrying you love
to overthink things look i understand
that behavior more than anyone could
imagine i'm a recovering warrior i'm a
recovering anxious person i've been
there i understand that but when we are
not in that vibration that's relaxed
released
at ease
present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low vibe
energy
is blocking
our high vibe attracting power
so what do you do
focus on the good stuff
lean into the positive look for
solutions rather than problems stop
yourself when you notice that you're
being judgmental or gossipy hang out
with people that make you feel good do
things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of joy the
universe
will deliver so if you're not attracting
what you desire just relax it's all good
focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally
we have the power within us
to attract what we desire when we allow
our internal condition to reflect what
we want to attract on the outside so
make that your highest priority a few
people ask a similar question to this
when visualizing do i need to let go of
it afterwards and forget about it
because that is what most stories on the
website tell or do i need to visualize
it every day i'm confused
so yes you let go of it
because it's already done so when you
visualize it you let it go it's already
done now
i talked about the secret a few weeks
ago and i said that i visualized it but
then every day i lived as though it was
already done i didn't visualize it every
day i
lived as though it was already done
and um and so
when you because all it takes is one
visualization yes
and so
why people say to let it go is because
is because if you are holding on to it
then you don't believe that you haven't
already
and you have to believe that you have it
already
so it's like this let's say you want a
dream car and
you've been saving for ages and you're
finally going to get your dream car you
you don't know you can manifest it
through the secret but you've been
saving freighters and you go to the
dealership and you test drive the car
and you say i'm going to buy this car
and you buy the car and you get in the
car and you drive it home
the next day you're going to visualize
wanting a new car
oh
why because you've already got it
right so that's how you have to feel you
visualize once it's already done
it's already done and so and so then you
let it go
and i'm sure for many many people uh
that they found that when they forgot
about it that's when it manifested
because when you forget about it you're
not holding onto it anymore right
so
yes so you do
um you do let you do let it go you
visualize and you do let it go the
problem with the concept of power of the
power positive thinking is people just
think oh well if i just have positive
thoughts then my life should be affected
and and this is why positive thinking
has a real bad rap in the public and the
reason is this having a positive thought
does not in any way necessitate that
those positive thoughts actually
manifest themselves and there's a piece
that was left out and if you don't
understand the piece then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this
when you're having positive thoughts
you're using your mind
the new biology reveals that the
invisible forces
that collectively we refer to as mind
that these form a field would shape
biology
well here's what's important yes the
mind influences biology but there are
two parts to the mind that are
completely different than one another
yet they work together we confuse them
we tie them together and yet they
represent two entities working in two
different fashions there's the conscious
mind
and what is called the subconscious mind
now here's what the very important
people have to know this okay and here's
what it is
the conscious mind is our creative mind
that is connected to our personal
identity and our spiritual selves that's
that makes us all unique our each of us
has our own personal conscious mind but
what becomes very significant is this is
the subconscious mind is equivalent to a
tape player it's exactly what it is it
records experiences and then plays them
back
and and so now let's take a look and say
wait there's a thinking mind
and then there's the tape player mind
and what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first
the
tape player the subconscious mind
as an information processor as the
equivalent of a computer
is a million
times more powerful on an information
processor than it's a conscious mind so
when you look at the power between the
conscious and subconscious subconscious
is a million times more powerful number
two
on a date by day basis
the subconscious mind runs our biology
about 95 to 99 percent of the time
so while you're having all these
wonderful thoughts
that's not the conscience the conscious
mind's not running the show it's a
subconscious mind
then it comes the issue is well the
subconscious mind got programs in it yes
and the and the subconscious mind is not
evil or good the subconscious mind is a
tape player as much as you can say
okay here here's a tape player it's good
or bad it's not the tape player is not
good or bad
the programs can be good and the
programs can be bad so blaming the
subconscious mind as a negative thing is
that's the first mistake it's a tape
player
the programs that we got that's the
source of the problems that most of us
face
and that these programs could limit our
abilities and take away our powers which
essentially they do now the relevance
about positive thinking is this
positive thinking is a creative thought
that comes from the conscious mind
okay so i sit here and i'm going to have
all these wonderful thoughts i'm going
to close my eyes and visualize all these
wonderful things now stop and go back to
the mechanical character of it a
i'm having these thoughts with a little
tiny processor called the conscious mind
and i'm competing with the programs that
are in the subconscious mind
so if i have a thought for
being being healthy or being in a good
relationship
and i'm doing positive thinking and at
the same time i've acquired programs in
my development that said you're not as
healthy as you think you are and you
you're not that good a person to have
those kind of relationships then look
i'm now pitting my positive thoughts
against my programs and and they're in
their opposite
but this one works on a little tiny
processor and this processor is a
million times more powerful so right
away it's like who's going to win in
that challenge the answer of course the
subconscious is going to win okay but
here comes the other part
while i can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than five percent of the day that
says 95 or more of the day i'm operating
from the other belief system
the point is do the math
how powerful are positive thoughts and
the answer is unless the subconscious
has the same programs and agreement
as the conscious mind power of positive
thinking will not work
it will not work because you're
competing against a much more powerful
processor now
here you have your senses
see here smell taste touch
you also have an imagination your
imagination
is a magnificent hill said it's the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force the world's ever known
there's a power flowing into your
consciousness
it never stops it flows to and through
you you can actually photograph this
energy leaving your body
you can learn to read it too i could
read your energy like a book
now as this energy comes in your
imagination gives you the ability to
build the picture
and you can build any picture you want
and what you want to do is with your
imagination build an image of something
absolutely incredible
and then
you turn it over to your subconscious
mind this is the part the early greeks
called the heart that's why solomon says
as a person thinketh in their heart so
are they because whatever is impressed
has to be expressed
so it's the image that you impress that
controls the vibratory rate of the
physical body
i was working with matt who's our in our
creative department
and today
and we've been working on a special
video that we're going to be putting out
you're going to you'll hear about it
and it's on
attraction the law of attraction
you see the law of attraction is a
secondary law it's not a primary law if
you don't understand the law of
vibration you're never going to
understand the law of attraction
and everybody's impacted by that
well
the visualizing is use the imagination
you've got to sit down and become the
actor and you start to see yourself with
the good that you desire and then as you
start to impress it this is your
emotional mind this is your intellectual
mind this is your emotional mind and as
you pass this over to the in the
emotional mind it sets up a vibration in
the body
and that's called feeling
so you're going to feel yourself already
with the good that you desire
now if you have to write a little note
to yourself and carry it around and hold
it in your hand and you just take a
little note hold it in your hand
every now and then stop for a few
minutes
go sit somewhere by yourself
and totally relax tell your body to
relax it's your body you're not a body
you live in a body so say just relax
just relax in fact try this right now
let all the muscles in your stomach
relax then we'll relax
let it all hang up come on just let it
hang out
now let your jaw relax
just let it relax you didn't even notice
your jaw wasn't relaxed just let it
relax now get yourself into a totally
relaxed state
and then start holding the picture and
getting emotionally involved with the
good that you desire
i mentioned something yesterday i'm
going to mention again because i think
it's very important get this book
this is stella adler's book
the art of acting it is an incredible
book really good
she was marlon brando's teacher
art of acting
you want to act like the person you want
to become way back 1900
william james said that it's the actor's
technique until you learn how to master
your mindset
by recognizing what's holding you back
the real reasons that you're not taking
the actions that you need to take
and learn how to reframe them in the
right part of your brain so you can
override the messaging signal from the
amygdala the fear center the emotional
center of the brain to the
part of the brain that's responsible for
taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties fear of success for your
failure if you're losing your job if
you're losing your home fear losing your
money
you have to understand that just like
a car
has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not
and if you're lacking the confidence and
the certainty
it's going to cause doubt if you're
going to have doubt it may cause anxiety
and as soon as that sets into the brain
in a nanosecond
your ability to take action
is like having one foot on the gas and
one foot on the brake
there's gonna be a lot of movement going
on the tires but you're really not gonna
get anywhere
so the first thing i want you to do
is write down what's really holding you
back
why aren't you really get clear get deep
why aren't you really taking action
towards any of your goals health goals
financial goals business goals whatever
goals you have
write that down
and ask yourself
is this real
is this imagined is it a probability
or is it a possibility what you'll find
for the most part is the negative
consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility you're going to do
everything possible to run away to fight
freeze or fight that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back to reframing the possibility to
do it from the probability to just a
normal possibility
you start to activate
different parts of your brain that
starts showing you the solutions to how
to overcome the fear how to overcome the
risk how to overcome the possible
negative consequence and then what
happens is the amygdala the part of your
brain that's responsible to protect you
and to keep you safe
the firing threshold of that signal gets
lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start to take action
and third what is happening
is that your left prefrontal cortex the
ceo the genius part of your brain
starts to think about ways that you can
actually take action and do it faster
and easier and better it starts to
change what you see start to change your
vibration and now you start to have a
lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action
the law of attraction definitely works
most people just get it wrong most
people only focus on the thinking part
and not the most important part which is
the action right law of attraction it's
the last five letters that matter a c t
i o
a c t i o n six the last six letters
that matter action action action
thinking about it alone is not enough so
it's the two parts you get an idea you
want something into your life you want
to manifest something amazing you want
success in your business you want a
happy relationship awesome you want to
speak on giant stages whatever the thing
is that you want in your life awesome
you have a vision board amazing just the
fact that you're thinking about it
and believing in it is already a big
step ahead of where most people are most
people live in a negative zone most
people feel like their life is hopeless
that they can't make a change that
they're stuck where they are and guess
what happens they stay exactly stuck
where they are right what you focus on
ends up becoming your reality so yes
you're going to focus on your new goal
your new habit the new thing that you
want into your life amazing you believe
that it's possible amazing you're
putting up a vision board with it on
your wall amazing you're researching and
watching videos like this every day
amazing that's great that's the first
starting point but nothing happens until
you take action
nothing happens until you take action
thinking alone is not enough
again it puts you ahead of most of the
most of the world puts you way ahead of
them but
you're still just going to be this super
smart super ambitious person sitting at
home not achieving your goals you have
to do something i look at my youtube
channel as an example uh my main channel
i want to get to 10 million subscribers
that's my next goal right we hit one we
hit two i gotta hit 10.
uh at the rate that we're growing it's
not fast enough like it's going to take
me way too many years to make it happen
so i need to apply more pressure against
it so
part of what i look at every day now in
my morning routine is i want to hit my
goal i want to get 10 million
subscribers on my youtube channel right
i want to be
you know one of the first uh thought
leaders experts business person to have
10 million subscribers on a youtube
channel it's my next goal great writing
that down every day doesn't make sure
that it's gonna happen what am i doing
right writing it down can lead to
thoughts that then lead to action but
what am i actually doing well i'll tell
you what i'm doing now
one of the biggest things i'm working on
now big new initiative for my team is
i've got 6 000 public videos on my main
channel and
i told my team
this week i want to go back and update
all of the thumbnails in all of the
titles across all my videos
that's a lot of videos right that's 6000
videos imagine doing split tests on all
of those videos
i asked for 10 a day and so two key
people on my team are working together
to come up with what the title is going
to be and then the other ones doing the
graphic design to create the thumbnails
maybe it works the first time but maybe
it doesn't
and it's a big ambitious project if you
think about it we got 6000 videos 10
videos a day
you know in a year if we did it for 10
videos every day we're just over half of
those videos assuming that they all work
out which they won't
so this is our test and if it works
awesome i might have that become
somebody's full-time job so that we can
do 20 slit tests a day 40 split tests a
day 100 split deaths a day i don't know
but it's happening to action right so it
starts with the idea if you have the
idea but you're not taking action you
won't get results if you just have the
action but you have no idea you're
running around with a chicken with your
head cut off you're going in circles
without any clear direction most people
think too much and don't do enough
that's most people some people do too
much and don't think enough some people
need more planning but in general most
people are over planners and so watching
this video alone is not enough
it's a great start it might boost your
motivation it might give you an idea to
go off and try watching my content
watching dan lok's content alone is not
enough it's the essential first piece of
the ingredient it's it's essential
surrounding yourself with people who
build you up who make you believe who
give you ideas you can act on that allow
you to feel like your goals are are
possible
that your dreams are within reach is
super important i do it every day it's
why i create all these channels i think
you should too you'll notice a
difference in how you think every single
day if you are creating content and
consuming content that builds you up
but then yourself to go take the second
step
it's why after every video i have a
question of the day or i have a
three-point landing question because i
want you to take action you need to
teach yourself that after every video
you watch up to every podcast you listen
to after every book that you read
but that's not enough you have to do
something about it i'd rather you watch
fewer videos read fewer books listen to
fewer podcasts consume less
if you're taking action on the ideas
that come to you because most people are
just professional
consumers
and it's great that you're consuming
educational content because most people
are just consuming stupid content right
you hate your life so you go watch
netflix all day when you get home for
five hours and then go to sleep right
you're a professional consumer but
you're consuming
uh wasteful content just entertaining
content
so you've already taken a step above
right you're consuming educational
content that's the next step you're
consuming educational content amazing
but still that alone is not enough what
separates the people go off and achieve
their dreams from the ones who just have
things on a vision board is that last
step of taking action so you're not
allowed anymore your new standards
you're raising your standards for
yourself you are not allowed anymore to
watch a video to read a book to listen
to a podcast to consume anything without
taking some kind of immediate action
towards it immediate action immediate
action it may not be the big thing
if you want to hit a million subscribers
on your youtube channel great what's the
immediate action film a video today make
an improvement to your thumbnail today
reach out for an interview for someone
today right immediate action teach
yourself that as soon as you get an idea
you do something about it because that's
the only thing that you're missing the
only thing that you're missing is
momentum if you're watching this channel
you believe in your talent you know
you're capable of more you've got big
goals big ambitions big dreams for
yourself the only thing you're missing
is momentum so to activate the law of
attraction pay attention to the last six
letters action and start doing something
about it once you start appreciating
your boss your clients
they appreciate you back so uh in my 20s
the reason why i like i was successful
was i was little uh unique
in so many different different things
for example when i was doing accounting
consulting i divided my uh clients to
two groups one i do regular job the
other i always
bring something whenever i got to meet
them just a herb tea japanese tea like a
book or just not super expensive
so in six months i got so many referrals
from the the gift giving groups you know
i didn't ask for any clients right but
they gave me uh so many referrals and
the second you know a group uh not so
much so
i
recommend
everybody to start giving more uh
something a little extra nuts like 30
more but something to to show
appreciation and
uh it doesn't really matter if you're a
florist or cleaners or business lawyers
or a dentist if you start giving
something you get more so
this is the law i think if you give more
you receive more and then
there's one more extra reason to
appreciate about
so you you your life would shift so your
whole energy would be so different and
so content and i think people want to do
business with happier people you know
people don't want to go with people who
are very depressed
so the people with the radiance of
appreciation often attracts more people
and more opportunities so this is not a
new age or a spiritual thing it's a
practice to to um to appreciate more so
what you appreciate appreciates and i
think it's it's so simple so start
appreciating about money is the first
step and then
second step is start appreciating what
you have and if you start sharing what
you have i call it gift
all of us have gifts i've written
probably like uh half of my books 20
books on how to discover your gifts and
monetize them
because
are born each of us is born with a
special gift and something to be shared
with this uh planet and if you can find
it and if you can uh improve it and you
can you can polish it and just
share with a society
i think
that translates into money so i wrote a
national bestseller
do what you love and make sure money
follows you so it's very important you
have to have both i think uh you know if
we everything starts with a thought i
mean everything that you do in your life
you you have to have a thought before
you initiate an action right so
so if you believe that your thoughts
have something to do with your destiny
like any great leader in history
understands that
the first thing you have to do is you
have to decide are you going to be
defined by a vision of the future
or are you going to live by the memories
of the past so give you an example
most people wake up in the morning and
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact of everything you've learned
and experienced to this moment right
it's a it's a memory bank
so most people wake up in the morning
and they start thinking about their
problems and those problems are
connected to certain people and things
at certain times and places
and the moment they start start turning
on those circuits those memories are
actually causing them to think in the
past
every single one of those memories has
an emotion associated with them and
emotions are the end product of past
experiences
so then the moment they recall the event
or the they recall some problem in their
life they start feeling unhappy they
start feeling discouraged they start
feeling anxious now thoughts of the
language of the brain and feelings of
the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates your
state of being so we could say then
most people's entire state of being when
they start their day is in the familiar
past well if you live in the familiar
past then it makes sense you're going to
create the predictable future so what
happens for most people is they get
stuck in their biology so think about
this
your body is your unconscious mind it
doesn't know the difference between an
experience in your life that creates an
emotion
and an emotion that you can create by
thought alone so if you're living by the
same emotion every single day and those
emotions are influencing your thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel or feelings have become the means
of thinking you're thinking in the past
your lens of the future is going to be
colored by the past so you can't see
possibilities so most people like to
wait for crisis or disease or diagnosis
before they wake up enough to see well
the challenge is is that biology tends
to be redundant so
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
and those thoughts be begin to fire
certain circuits in your brain the nerve
cells that fire together wire together
so all of a sudden you start getting
hardwired and those are the thoughts
that you can think the easiest at the
same time those thoughts produce
chemicals called emotions and the next
thing you know your body gets accustomed
to living by the same emotions and it
could be guilt it could be unhappiness
it could be pain but at least it's
familiar to you at least you can predict
it so some people would rather cling to
the familiar than take a chance in
possibility so
for most people then they say well
i don't really see how my thoughts have
anything to do with my destiny well
that's because
95 of those thoughts are subconscious
programs right so you're not even
conscious that you think those thoughts
so the first step to change
is starting to think about what you've
been thinking about and change it and
and then when you begin to observe those
thoughts you're no longer the program
you're the consciousness observing just
simply by being an observer of your
thoughts right so so though so most
people though when they when you do that
when you decide to really take a look
it's like lighting a match in a dark
place
so you feel uncomfortable so it's easier
to turn on your tv it's easier to
play with your cell phone to distract
yourself from those feelings well
when you understand that change really
requires becoming uncomfortable to a
certain degree and that's normal that
you're leaving the known and you're
stepping into the unknown then it begs
the question what thoughts do you want
to fire and wire in your brain because
your attention on those thoughts begins
to reorganize circuitry re-mold the
brain we had a thanksgiving where
literally we had no food and we wouldn't
have starved but we weren't gonna have a
thanksgiving dinner
and uh there was a knock at the door and
that knock changed my life because it
was someone who delivered food for us it
was just a delivery man the person who
actually sent it
didn't acknowledge who they were and the
man said this is just a gift for you and
your family
my father didn't react very well to it
at the time um didn't want charity but
out of necessity he took it in and i
just remember at that time thinking to
myself
why is it that my father worked so hard
because he did work he wasn't unemployed
and yet here we are with no money on
thanksgiving not even for food
and
it's just
my whole life had been that way and i
just i couldn't understand why we were
living on the other side of the tracks i
lived in what i thought was a rich
community it was actually a middle class
community lower middle class but
everybody else we live right next the
railroad tracks quite literally and
everyone seemed like living a different
lifestyle and i couldn't understand my
father i felt was as good as their
fathers as a person why did we have such
lack why was there such scarcity why did
they have so much abundance in us not
have any
and i really didn't have the answer
until i sat in that room with jim rohn
and he asked a question he said you know
what does it really take
to do well financially what does it take
to have real economic abundance
and he said you must bring value to the
marketplace i'll never forget
and i thought what the hell is he
talking about value to the marketplace
and he made it very clear that we all
have value in our own souls but that's
not what we get paid for we also get
paid for effort we don't get paid for
our time we get paid to find a way to
add value and the question he asked at
the time was how is it possible that
some people
earn twice as much money as you do or
four times or five times or ten times as
much money in the same amount of time
and he said the answer is because they
found a way to add more value
that is the secret to abundance do more
for others than anyone else on earth and
if you can do that you can build a brand
you can build a company you can build a
life you can build friendships that are
beyond compare
and so that simple little philosophy was
really simple he went a little deeper he
was very specific he said you know if
you look at it i remember at the time he
said if you work for mcdonald's in those
days he said you make 250 an hour
and i remember he said you know
somebody's working making 250 now and
they're barely surviving today working
mcdonald's you make eight dollars an
hour by contrast for a little inflation
but this is 1977. and he said so why do
these people make so little and somebody
that he gave the example back then of
the gentleman who was uh the head of
disney and he's made 52 million dollars
in the same year
one person's making 250 an hour somebody
just makes 52 million
so how is that possible isn't that fair
isn't that unfair
and i remember at the time in pausing
and saying well anybody can learn within
an hour
how to really
do the numbers and use a cash register
in fact today you don't even know the
numbers you just push a button with a
picture on it right so anybody can do
that it's not being disrespectful so
there's not a lot of added value in fact
soon robotics will probably take most of
that over because it's it's not
something that expands the human spirit
it's not a complex task that makes us
expand or grow and offer something
but he said you know the guy that
figured out how to turn disney around
with having trouble it's worth 52
million because he's bringing joy and
happiness and love and laughter to
millions and millions of people so if
you help millions of people
you're going to do well
in the bible it says if you wish to
become great learn to become the servant
of many
which as jim used to say is you know
that means there's nothing wrong with
wanting to be great
but greatness comes from serving a large
number of people or at a deep level one
of the two and so you look at it today
and today the story is the same you work
at mcdonald's it's eight dollars an hour
and i just got finished writing a book
where i interviewed 50 of the most
successful financial people on earth
that started with nothing and you look
at a guy last year david tupper was the
highest paid hedge fund guy he got paid
3.5 billion dollars last year now that
looks like incredibly unjust experience
you know it's insane it's insane to
think that that man's going to make 3.5
and someone else going to make 15 000 a
year at 8 an hour basically how how
could you justify that
well
if you find a way to add more value you
can earn more and you can be abundant he
figured a way to get a 40 return for
people
in a world where most people are putting
their money in a savings account getting
33 basis points one third of one percent
if you got people one percent return
he'd be having 300 more value but he's
adding 12 000 more value for his
investors these people have taken their
money and they're able to do things for
their families for their businesses for
the causes they care about because he's
growing it at a multiplied level because
he developed this incredible set of
skills and how did he do it the way jim
rohn teaches he learned to work harder
on himself he learned to master skills
no one else had that could add value to
others so introducing you to jim rohn in
abundance i just want to mark out that
you can earn 10 times more 20 times more
100 times more in the same amount of
time if you work harder on yourself than
anything else if you find a way to do
more for others than anyone else
and then it goes beyond money
then it goes to
understanding abundance as an emotion
like love
like joy
it's the most amazing thing the more of
it that we give the more of it we
experience inside everything is possible
you know when you believe
that's
the kind of kicker you have to believe
but it's not that hard it's really
pretty easy
our belief
creates our entire life experience
and so
you can't if i put it this way you can't
experience anything in life
that is outside of your own beliefs
so and that's that's the case for every
single one of us we really can't
experience anything
that's outside of our beliefs if we
can't experience anything that's outside
of our beliefs
what that means is look at all those
hearts that's so beautiful
what that means is there's not really
one world we kind of think there's one
world but there isn't really
because we're all experiencing
a world based on our beliefs and not one
of us has the same beliefs not one of us
so that means there's a different world
for every one of us
so
all of your beliefs
are held in your subconscious mind and
the subconscious mind is just a part of
your mind there's the conscious mind and
then there's the subconscious mind using
actual which is actually higher than the
conscious mind and so we use our
conscious mind with all of the thoughts
and everything that we have our
conscious mind is very present right
and so
to create anything
you are using your subconscious mind
your subconscious mind is what
is really what creates if i want to make
it really really simple
then i would say your subconscious mind
is what creates
it makes things appear
and manifest things
and that's where all of your beliefs are
stored kind of neat huh
because you have to believe to manifest
something
and your subconscious mind creates
everything so you can see it's all kind
of perfectly designed
um so now to manifest you have to
believe
and
you have to believe that you already
have whatever it is that you want
and the reason that you have to believe
you have it already is because the
subconscious mind
is only operating in the present
it can't reason
it's just like a program so if you say
for example
um
a new car is coming my new car is coming
i'm going to get a new car it's coming
well then it's always going to be coming
right that's the that's the thing you
have to imagine you have it now you have
to go off and you have to test drive the
car you've got to feel the car smell the
car and just then
visualize being in that car
and then when you do that that's how
if you do that enough that's how you'll
come to believe that you actually have
the car and the moment that you believe
is manifestations instantaneous
so
so
the other ways to believe is to affirm
over and over and over um
so
to be really repetitive for example
um to visualize and visualizing is
incredibly powerful
because when we close our eyes and we
put ourselves in the picture and you
must make sure you're in the picture
and you put yourself in the picture with
whatever it is that you want and you
close your eyes and you just kind of
create this mini movie
honestly
the subconscious mind does not know that
you're imagining it has no idea
it just sees that movie and recreates it
it's like a giant photocopying machine
it will just whatever you hold in your
mind it will
photocopy it warm into the world
so
um so if you are thinking about
something in the future it's always
going to be in the future so you have to
imagine that you have it now you have to
act as if
and um for example
if you wanted to attract a perfect
partner
are you acting as if your perfect
partner is here already and so there are
just small things that you can do that
are super super powerful for example are
you sleeping in the middle of your bed
or are you sleeping on one side of the
bed because your partner's on the other
side of the bed
do you have room in your wardrobe for
your perfect partner's clothes
is there room in your bathroom for their
toothbrush and for their things and so
you see they are just little things you
can set the table for two you don't have
to put food on the plate but just
setting the table for two is really
really powerful it's saying my perfect
partners here already and the
subconscious mind will believe it
and your perfect partner will be
attracted to you through the most
incredible circumstances so
um if something hasn't manifested yet
and you really really want it and i i
doubt there's anybody out there who's
who wants something and it hasn't
manifested right i mean
um i'll tell you the reason why it
hasn't manifested is because you don't
believe you have it in order to start
attracting money into your life you have
to first have an understanding of what
money is and your relationship to your
finances that sounds like such a strange
statement to say your relationship with
your finances but we all have feelings
and relationships to thoughts and
objects how you feel about something
determines how you can attract it into
your life everything is energy and in
order to attract certain things into
your life you have to be an energetic
match and understand your relationship
to that object love is one of the most
powerful vibrations you can tap into so
whenever possible
shift your feelings towards love
so what is your relationship to money be
honest with yourself do you get nervous
to check your bank account do you feel
anxious that you don't have enough money
do you constantly tell yourself that you
can't afford things do you think that
only lucky people deserve money do you
think you have to work long hours at a
job you hate in order to earn enough
money
i used to have that last belief and i
was stuck for way too long at a job i
hated working crazy long hours to
support the kind of life that i wanted
to deserve
and once i shifted my mindset i realized
that none of that was worth it
once i shifted this mindset everything
started flowing to me so much quicker
and easier and i wasn't stuck at a job
that i hated anymore i want you to write
down a list of everything you feel
towards money all of your thoughts
feelings emotions doubts opinions write
it all down get very clear and be
completely honest with yourself pause
this video now and take as much time as
you need
after you write down your belief system
about money
look at specific areas at where you can
improve your money mindset for example
are you scared to check your bank
account how can you turn that around and
make it into a more positive action can
you start checking it more often and
release that fear that you don't need
can you use a positive affirmation each
time you look at that statement
can you meditate and visualize your bank
account with six figures do whatever is
in your power to shift your money
mindset so that everything lines up to
be clear and positive by understanding
your relationship with money and
releasing the fear or negative feelings
surrounding it you can be open to
attracting more of it into your life
how can you admit the frequency of love
surrounding money the vibrational
frequency of love is so unbelievably
strong that if you can tap into that
power money will flow to you at record
speed trust me there are so many ways to
add the frequency of love into your
money mindset for example you can
visualize how you would spend that money
on the people you love you can start
loving the money that you currently have
you can start generously making
donations to people in need and coming
from a place of love you can make vision
boards of all the things that you would
treat yourself to with that money give
yourself some self-love
you can meditate with the feeling of
love while visualizing complete
financial freedom
or one of my favorites you can visualize
your heart as a powerful magnet
strongly attracting money directly into
your reality
try out a few of these and see which one
works best for you now that you're clear
on your money mindset and infused it
with the vibration of love i want to
share with you the magic formula for
manifesting this formula is something i
go into more depth in my digital course
abundance academy but because this
formula really works i want to share it
with you thought has the magnetic force
thought coupled with feelings is even
stronger thought coupled with feelings
mixed with inspired action is where
manifesting occurs or put simply
thought plus feelings plus inspired
action equals manifesting welcome to
manifesting math class
like i said earlier everything starts
with thought and mindset you have to be
clear and understand what your thoughts
are towards money before you can start
to manifest it into your life once you
are clear on your thoughts it's time to
infuse it with feelings i suggest
infusing with love because it's the most
powerful frequency but if you want to
choose another feeling feel free do
whatever works best for you you can try
joy excitement happiness comfort peace
of mind or any feeling that you can emit
at a high frequency and this last step
is one that most people miss or skip in
their manifesting process
inspired action inspired action is one
of the most important and most
overlooked steps
taking an inspired action doesn't have
to be a huge deal it doesn't have to be
this overwhelming stressful thing so
don't worry inspired action can be as
simple as writing a check to yourself
for a hundred thousand dollars as a hint
to your subconscious that that's what
you're trying to create or
making a small donation to charity
because you are doing it from a place of
abundance or
following that urge you had to write
that blog or start that business or
follow up on that email your intuition
is always trying to communicate with you
and by taking guided inspired actions
you are directly aligning with whatever
it is that you're trying to manifest
get in touch with your intuition and see
what inspired action you're guided to
take there is always an option to take
an inspired action so take advantage of
it think of your intuition like your
fairy godmother you follow your
manifesting formula of thought plus
feeling and your intuition or your fairy
godmother will guide you to exactly
where you need to be in order to
manifest what you want but it's up to
you to follow that intuition and take
that step or inspired action with this
mindset work and manifesting formula you
are well on your way to start attracting
money into your life easily and
effortlessly but you have to remember
that you are in charge of redirecting
your negative thoughts or feelings about
money when they come up because they
will come up from time to time and just
remember that you are in charge of
shifting it right back to where you need
to be you need to get to the point of
ignoring your current or outside
circumstances and standing firm in a
place of faith that you are abundant
whenever you get a bill in the mail pay
it and be grateful that you're
contributing to someone else's financial
betterment whenever you feel stressed
about finances redirect yourself and
realize how lucky you are that you have
a roof over your head and clean water
and people that love you and send love
out to those that aren't as fortunate
whenever you feel like you can't afford
something this is my favorite just go
virtual shopping start coming from a
place of financial freedom and clicking
and putting in your cart all of those
things you want to buy online pick
anything you want the sky is your limit
you don't actually have to purchase
anything but by virtually shopping and
feeling that financial freedom and
adding those things to your cart you're
sending a clear message to your
subconscious mind that you can have that
and then it'll be on its way
feel powerful that you have this
superpower knowledge that you are
consciously creating your reality use
this power to shape your reality and
banish the negative beliefs you have
around money our society will constantly
condition you that you need more of this
or better things and that you have to
work really really hard to achieve
things in life but not for you
you now have the knowledge that by
shifting your mindset and taking
inspired action money will flow to you
without all the bullsh
so congratulations on taking your first
step towards financial freedom remember
that you are powerful you are worthy and
you are abundant
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to attract things quickly check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there waiting for the outer
environment to change
to take away this feeling of anger
resentment emptiness
but they forgot that they create reality
in other words when it finally appears
that i'm going to feel love that's
that's cause and effect